quite full bloom man it was great i
really like the way they captured the
art of fighting the art of war and i
love the way they put it in such a
unique and wise way it was powerful
i just wanna let you guys know that i
just saw one of the best movies of all
time the name of it is in full bloom
it was empowering to see
a japanese champion facing an american
challenge
it's about two guys fighting each other
from different countries with the weight
of their pupils on their shoulders
[Music]
you feel like you are on the journey
with people fighters
a lot of drama fights
action everything
in full bloom available now on amazon
prime video
and the other one i want to
put them in in golf
they're gonna be excited maybe they
don't like it better i don't think it
would be exciting it's exciting yeah for
golf yeah he's excited one day i had a
plane go off and i turned into the ball
the thing came out of my hand boom broke
somebody's car
[Music]
what's up everybody henry cejudo aka
triple c
and i'm mike tyson and today we have a
special guest today canelo alvarez the
super champion everybody oh come
coach of the year right
one one one one soon to be two so tell
us man what's this all about man who's
the next guy you planning on fighting i
was at your last fight i mean this guy
yeah the guy didn't come and killed him
man he went there to make a payday
no
but
uh
[Music]
yeah he said he uh you know it was a
mandatory fight for him and then now he
has he's up too bigger he's got now he's
gonna move up to 168 pounds and meet up
with saunders and he's looking to just
collect more belts and more gold to his
resume the best time one of the
champions
yeah
yeah he's a champion for the wbo yes
he's cool from so who's been around the
beach and no one can just gonna be
hanging
out you know the fight you move up to 78
75 no it's it it's difficult to go
too much
way up it's difficult for what about
you
168 only 68 168 is my is my way now and
i feel good i i feel in my best moment
so
i i feel like and anybody can beat me
right now so who do you got to fight out
there who do you want to fight
anybody anybody
the best fighter out there
and who's that
i'm gonna fight with billy joson there
is one of the best in 168 i used fight
in
in december and that last december i
fought with the number one in 168 yes i
beat him
and then i'm
i'm going forward yeah and this is the
thing too mike with canelo it's a rarity
for a mexican
to be a champion at the weight class
that he ours because remember we have
barrera all these guys are all like 20
30 uh 35 pounders i mean this guy's
moving at 268 pounds and you know which
is you know again it's a rarity for
mexican
he's awesome man
what do you guys what do you ever think
about doing outside of boxing
is
[Music]
yeah he said right now his you know he's
he's he's smart about what he does with
his money he's investing his money i
mean but he's doing what he loves right
now and that's just boxing but he says
you know he wants to live on the the
investment that he's that he's done now
you know for the rest of his life but
right now his priority his love is a
sport of boxing
so how many fights do you think you have
before you retire
maybe
seven years more
oh that's so awesome
[Laughter]
when did you feel at your peak mike when
did you feel like you're the strongest
for you no i i think he's different
because he's
uh heavyweight he's
he can go more gears yeah no yeah
everybody's last longer than the little
guys
he says you already
said you're still fighting yeah yeah
less weight is more pointless
yeah like i think there's more volume
when it comes to like the lighter guys
you have to be
loosely because so much incoming from
smaller guys they throw a lot of punches
yeah but then you guys man you know you
zig you zag and you get caught as a
heavyweight your ass is your ass is out
you know be careful yeah it's tricky in
there that's streaky yeah i have a i'm
kind of curious with you canelo what
were some of the mexican fighters
growing up that you felt that you
admired because i remember growing up
were somewhat similar age i remember
barretta morales
trilogy i used that for my brother my
older brother
but and then
eddie
showed me a lot of videos of gilberto
roman julio
um
not too much
yeah i'm curious to know where did you
get your left hook to the body and then
you go like fake the left hook to the
upper did you did you find that in you
did you take that from somebody that you
that inspired you with that left hook to
the body and then coming up top in the
gym with eddie
i i learned in the gym with eddie and he
have
a lot of experience he he loves to learn
every day so
i i find sometimes
by myself to
do things but uh i learned from it from
eddie
did you know crystal ball christopher
used to work with um
yeah he said he said he he liked the
resistance that salvador brought but he
said technically there's a little more
mexican legends that that he looked up
to and that he studied disease
i loved um
i think um sanchez is hard to be he's
one of those guys
that um this was making him so special
with sanchez
this has made him really special
to me and everybody that knows his style
if you if you're a halfway fighter
decent fighter you might
last the distance as good as you are
you're greater you are the more he kicks
your ass
he fights right above the level of the
game that he's fighting
you will ask him he's going to [ __ ] you
up he's just he's just above everybody
else yeah and last time he was just such
a bad [ __ ] you're talking about
salvador yeah yeah he died yeah he was a
bad [ __ ] yeah he'd be the zoom
and never zoom in the animal he'd be oh
man
well we'll freddie gomez
um
[ __ ] bazooka gomez yeah i'm so i'm
and i think about that i'm thinking
about all the like the trilogies like
you know the barrera morales you've
always had either mexican spiders or
mexicans fighting against puerto rico
but for for canelo my qui uh uh i'm
curious to see how was it when you
fought chavez because you guys were
these two countrymen how is it that you
were accepted after the fight was kind
of took place for me it's a fight for
that fight
we have
prominent problems like when i was 16
years old yeah we we need to make that
fight and then do you guys know each
other in the amateurs yeah yeah
no no no no no no much we don't
no but you guys knew each other was the
problem because it's 16 years old no
you're a pro now
and then
but he have the
the
the torch you know he
he is the guy to make that fight in that
time yeah and then i'm growing up and
getting better and
do my job
and then i i make that fight
no but uh that fight was easy for me
yeah no i know that but how was it with
the mexican people you know like the
people going crazy
yeah yeah did you feel like there are
more with you or with him because even
though chavez jr is the legend son he's
kind of hating him mexico mike
not hated but not as appreciated with me
all most of the people yeah
how are you living how your father's a
[ __ ]
amazing mother how you guys live in that
shadow
even if you look he was a champion even
if he was he became champion but [ __ ]
that's being a champion is like a
beginner compared to him
yeah you know
what i mean 88 fights without being beat
89 fights something like that yeah yeah
yeah 89
super records you're gonna notice you
ain't gonna live to see that again i'm
not gonna say that
you're not
let's never do that yeah absolutely
legend man absolutely
so eddie i wanna talk to a little bit
about uh canelo how was it when did you
see there was a special gift with canelo
obviously you know i've known a bit
about his story no he would fight a lot
because people would make fun of his
freckles or the fact that you know he
had a different hair color how was them
the first time you met him what made him
special
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah he said he was abnormal as a kid
like 13 14 years old he was already you
know dropping guys that were 17 18.
is there everybody that's short and
stocky in mexico and guadalajara they're
from or in mexico in general they call
it they call emini tyson
actually
i've been there before
yeah that's that's where they make our
tequila mic
tequila jalisco yeah
you know who's that other fighter
jose ramirez jose ramirez oh he was
tough too sopa
yourself for you he was tough too
he dropped the whale
alexis out of the way
the man got me into boxing hey roberto
duranted yeah what's him fighting i said
wow
i want to do this
he then what he said uh eddie wants to
know who is your favorite fighter
oh god
ali the red
robinson
robinson but at least you're you're
muslim tequila
i love all the violet most people
there's so many
it's not one fighter that could do
everything
like one guy could do one thing
you know there's one guy that has the
left hook that's just it's just better
than everybody else and looks better
than anybody else even though he's not a
better fighter but his punches it's just
weird fighting it's weird yeah it's just
people that look good fighting
even if they're not good fighters
you know it's just weird some people are
born like that
you know they just look good doing
everything even losing
yeah and it's crazy because customer now
lee were born in the same day
how random is that [ __ ] happens someone
has to be born in that day yeah
[ __ ] two legends
yeah brothers and sisters and they have
a brother that box right so seven
seven brothers and sisters
seven brothers and one sister
who yeah and all them fighting in one
time
before professional
oh [ __ ] man
that's crazy where do you fall on the
ladder of the seven
where do you fall what number the the
youngest oh he's the youngest i'm the
youngest you're the youngest yeah that
explains it man
i'm the youngest
that explains it yeah people think
because you're the youngest
you know you get beat up you know that's
how i'm i'm the second youngest so i
kind of get a little taste of what he's
and laugh of me
and everything i need to
do something
yeah
no more what you want to do business
business man enjoy my life and have my
my
my my business now um
i have many things to do
since you got organization with your
fighters right you were stable of
fighters i don't
know jed i don't like
to be involved in boxing after i'm
retired but i have eddie so eddie loved
boxing and
and maybe in some point
yeah it's just pretty cool too with
canelo mike is because he's always
stayed low with this coach you know you
know you know wrestling
yeah you know rest in peace you know
custom model but i know you know the
loyalty that he has for his coach is the
same loyalty you have for you have to
have loyalty yeah you have to be
prepared to do anything for one another
yeah because i remember watching an
interview with canelo they don't they
don't care
they don't care money
of course they care but uh the first
thing they they care is you
and then the rest of that
yeah that's that's why you need people
like like them because it's difficult to
find people
in
in life that like they are
i understand that because people have to
protect me from me because i don't think
i'm as poor as they think i am yeah you
know
they they they looking
to say to to castesbian
you look at your well-being
you would and then the other thing
coming
yeah because even i remember when uh you
know obviously you employed you know you
lost to floyd and they had ash you know
you're going to be switching trainers
you're like no no i said i don't catch
with trainer i know
what happened and
i'm gonna be with my trainers all my
life yeah because i know
and now that you're older now canelo
obviously you're 28 now i believe you
fought mayweather when you're 21.
how do you think
you're 30 now i'm 10.
when i fought with floyd i was
23 23.
how much have you grown from 23 now so
much i
i always seven years
i always think i i i need to fight first
with coro
lara
and all of that guys and then floyd
that's what it is yeah no
that's that's what it is uh i'm okay so
you think at 23 you think you're it was
still it was kind of premature i need i
need more experience more mature
yeah i think that helps them more than
anything fights like that
helps you want to handle you
let me say well i can go
12 rounds with the best fighter in the
world
yeah that makes you better yeah i i
agree with that i don't i don't take
that fight like i lose
i take that fight like i i'm learned
from that fight because because of that
loss
this is where he's at now yeah that's
why when you think about that that loss
puts him here yeah because i remember to
mike when i talked to you and you always
say like the fight that really that you
felt like a world champion when you'd be
larry holmes yeah right
for you canelo what was that fight that
that that made you feel
that great feeling as a warrior
when i fought with
miguel cora i was basically that one too
yeah
one of the one of my best best fight i
i feel like i feel like
when i when i won that fight i feel like
oh okay here is my
yeah
my best moment is coming yeah especially
the fact that it was uh for you mike it
was because he had beaten ali you know
your hero the legend
you know for him
it was the mexican puerto rico rivalry
that you know what i mean against the uh
i imagine like um coda was dry and then
he was on a hot streak for a while
that's when he fourteen was hot he had a
hot streak
you you took the title from him right
yeah yeah he had a hot streak when he
fled up you know he started beating
people
somebody for him and his brother you
know your brother not with throat
what trouble
yeah
my brother loves with with yeah
what do you think this world is about
since you've been living what do you
absorb from this world what do you think
about people
especially
he said that life is about enjoyment of
what you do every single day
sometimes people are worried about
what's going to happen
that's what's worth there
there
yeah you have to pretty much just sum it
up he says
you know life life is living in the
present every day obviously plan for the
future but if you don't live in the
present you know the future will never
come
yeah president um is going every time
you talk
the president is gone
and it's in the past yeah
you know
yeah so it's almost like living in the
now right yeah you're like that mike
well um
i can't allow my path to you know have
any kind of [ __ ] um
impact on my future yeah
that's what i that's what i
yeah
speaking about that no i know the boxing
world has gone through a lot like what
you which what's your take canelo on uh
on this whole uh jake paul and
everything that's going on and what how
that's turned how that is fighting jake
paul
jake paul is fighting ben askren you
know ben askren he's a fighter yeah he's
mma fighter
yeah yeah
they've been able to kill him
okay i'm going to give you okay so uh
ben ashken he's a two-time ncaa champion
he was actually my olympic teammate in
2008
he fought he's a ufc fighter but he
didn't go so well for him but he's also
a troll a guy likes to go on the
internet and talk stuff [ __ ]
so jake so is jake paul but the thing is
is like it's different because this ben
ashton guy he can't grapple and boxing
doesn't matter who you are because you
box is different
it's completely different listen what's
so interesting about boxing like you get
mma guys the guy's got better hands you
can grab them yeah if you're boxing the
guy's really better head you gotta do a
lot of things a little bit long night
yeah you know you throw faster you
harder you're like [ __ ] he's smart hard
to hit
then some thinking yeah and i i think i
feel like i've noticed something in
boxing too that
mma guys don't bring and you guys have a
certain pressure
and fakes that so like deceiving like it
it's different when you fight an mma guy
and you fight a boxer they're very
composed and they stalk you like well
you're like afraid because you don't
know what's coming because mma you got
legs on the elbows and stuff boxing just
have this yeah
so you have yeah which makes it which
makes it a whole lot more difficult but
to get back to that what's your take on
on jake paul and the things that are
going on in boxing right now do you
think that's good for boxing or what's
your take on that
anybody can do whatever it is that they
want to desire but he says boxing's no
joke i mean nate robinson he said he had
no he had no reason to become a
professional boxer i mean look at him he
said they made him they left him half
dead after that fight i mean this is
this isn't a joke either listen um
imagine how he feels when he comes
outside
the [ __ ]
you talk about you talk about uh
robinson yeah
he was on he was on your undercard mic
you gotta deal with this [ __ ]
uh uh eddie wants to know when's your
next when are you going to fight next
you can probably drop the you can
probably drop the news now mike may in
fight a
may 8th
the weekend of cinco de mayo oh that's
always packed travis should always fight
there yeah
memory for the azteca arena in
mexico that's amazing
yeah that'd be cool that'd be cool
canelo to see you do something like that
like allow you to fight i wanted to
fight in mexico the last fight but uh
with the pandemic it's so difficult to
bring people
yeah man you say mexico will be jammed
oh man
city
yeah but mexico the uh that stadium i
think it fits like a hundred fifty
thousand or something crazy like that
yeah
travis sold that place out of that tech
here yeah yeah so he said about a
hundred thousand he sold it out and he
was still born people wanting to come in
chap is a monster when he was fighting
yeah it's just you couldn't it was like
the president walking down the street in
any
mexican community vague is colorado
jesus was a [ __ ] god
yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah but it's almost like this
too because you think about somebody
like chavez mike you know and it happens
to a lot of boxers unfortunately but you
know they fall into
kind of that trap of listen um money is
the art it's all taking care of money
you know some of the greatest
businessmen
they make great they do not take care of
money
um it's really hard it's really hard yes
it's art
so the hardest thing is
he said the fame is the most dangerous
thing do you agree mike
well let me tell you
i'll say something different
it's the same thing but it's just a
different word i think that camera right
there
is a narcotic
if you're not caught once you see
yourself on there you see wow i could
look better if i did this
and then you're hooked yeah we listen
all of us we're [ __ ] up we're [ __ ]
up right we don't even know it
we think we're arrogant we're cool with
this [ __ ] us up
yeah we changed our attitude
consciousness while we're here
see look at it look at you is that
looking this is a drug that changes you
once it's on you
you change
you change automatically yeah you guys
are almost saying the exact same thing
and he's saying the fame but obviously
you're getting a little you're more in
the little macro saying hey it's it's
more almost more self-love would you say
no no no this is what self-love is
self-love is um
doing for him what you want done for
yourself
self-love is not
internal love is external love
really
yeah i think that might be more vanity
oh yeah you know what turn the camera
off listen um
vanity has this place too you know how
this place for um
people to lower self-esteem
and they look in the mirror and they
love themselves so bradley has
had his purpose
when you say don't you go in the mirror
all the time
yeah i'm just i'm like that's what we do
i said i'm just glad i'm not losing my
hair mike
looks good
i see myself in there i'm a short ass
dude that's what i see
you're a giant yeah
yeah i appreciate it yeah baby
three three hold
thirteen
two and three holy [ __ ]
thirteen is a boy huh yeah yeah
oh i have a 12 year old daughter she's
like i'm a prodigy in tennis dennis one
of the best in the country she will be
pro one day nice yeah
she can do it so what do you do to kids
my older daughter is
riding horses what's this jumping
wow
she's a
champion in mexico
and the other one i want to
to
put them in engulf
they're gonna be exciting maybe they
don't like it better i don't think it'll
be exciting it's exciting yeah for golf
yeah he's excited one day i
i was playing golf and i turned into the
ball the the thing came out of my hand
and boom
hey i think the same as you when i when
i don't
play when i when i went
before when i don't play
golf i say it's boring it's boring when
i start playing oh it's
that's what everybody tells me amazing
it's a hangout talking shoot with your
friends amazing is that her issue
right
yeah how is it with your kids canelo
obviously you're a superstar you know in
mexico
all across the world but especially you
know i can only put i can only put
myself in your kid's shoes
how is it that do they feel that
pressure from their dad being a champion
even you too mike obviously if anybody
knows it you know
my life
privacy kind with my kids and they know
they
always come
but i always
for me the most important thing in life
is my privacy
i know it's so difficult
you should
if you're that kind of person you should
be in private you should respect that
yeah what about you mike what about with
you and uh
you know because there's a lot of times
when champions have kids it's almost
like the kids when we talk about travis
jr it's almost like they become in the
you know they feel like they live in the
shadow of of their fathers
how do you distribute that how do you
cope with that mike with your kids
i just let them know that i love them
whatever they do in life as long as
they're happy
you know i mean i don't expect them to
be world-beated
but they're all very successful but um
i just don't i try not to give them
tonight show them love it's all love
always involved with them
listen to the problems sending them
money and i just never put anything
about me
you know if i talk about me it's only
about my experience in life
that equated to what they were talking
about
but i try to put my perspective on in
a father's figure not
just pay attention and you what you do
know what your father is doing
because no one believes that they they
enjoy him being the champ
but they don't look at him as he's the
champ during this fight yeah that's just
their excitement but when he's back home
that's his dad yeah isn't that why it's
just that everybody else
i do it too but when we're home to cut
the [ __ ] that's just that is there
something
this is that dad can't go out the door
yeah and have a cup of coffee what kind
of life is that anything you know that
comes with
great talent yeah and it's beautiful
because you'll never have you know
people can fanboy i mean i'm around you
all the time mike you know people i can
see people grown men everybody fanboys
over you but your kids
oh my kids
oh man so my kids are going like this
out of the blue man johnson bigger than
you now he's more popular what the [ __ ]
i don't get out of here and my daughter
beyonce is bigger than you too
where's this coming for and then that's
my daughter and i know you don't think
you fly the michael jackson or prince
where's this coming from
you know my kids always trying to bust
my chops and they say i get all this
attention to i don't know why they
should be able to imagine johnson
johnson's bigger than you my kids will
say that how many how many kids
i got one two three boys
and four girls
ones the
third one the fifth grade and one was in
college
[Music]
those ones graduate a lot of the kids
they graduated from
new york
nyc drexler
and american college
and that's what they have a brother it's
a brain surgery that's some [ __ ] i can't
[ __ ] barely read and write this kind
of brain so do this [ __ ] a couple of my
friends were shot he went there and sold
them up
he said mikey that's your brother your
mother my brother saved a couple of my
friends likes
they've been shot or something they sold
them up
that's your brother yes it is my brother
no no your brother's
that's crazy you know i wasn't good in
school i just couldn't understand the
[ __ ] the division you got to jump and
take this number and take
one from three oh god when i was two
i was not interested in what they had to
teach
the teachers that is
i always want to fight after i gave up
school and started fighting
i'm the same i don't i don't like the
school no way
i'm doing so i'm looking out the window
waving people out
it's horrible in school
dan that's that's crazy canelo um a
question that i have for you is like how
do you see yourself in sports you know
obviously you have the
lebron james the ronaldo's people that
have made a huge impact in just sports
in general you know where do you where
do you place yourself amongst a lot of
these legends that have that have done
big things and not just boxing but in
sports in general
[Music]
[Music]
his legacy wants to be to represent the
latino community as much as possible he
doesn't feel like
they're respected as much as they should
be whether it's in business
or just in life or just here in the us
for that matter he wants you know his
legacies to to you know to be respected
not just as a boxer because they all
respect the ma you know mexicans
especially in boxing but just in general
he wants to make that impact and uh and
change and change it in that and that
was he willing to contribute to make
that um a reality because it is
[Music]
is
yeah he said he's doing it now with his
example he says if he can become the
best at a certain craft you can become
the best at life and just just in
general so he's he's doing he's doing it
now i mean he's got you know he wants to
fight for the next seven years which you
know
that's a long time right now
seven years will come so damn fast
you'll see so many people grow and die
and all that stuff so here's nothing
yeah
before before we wrap up here uh eddie
uh canelo you guys have any you guys
have any questions for mike you know
growing up with mike you know do you
guys have any questions for him i know
he gets a lot but i just wanna say that
i'm unhappy
to see him well back healthy for me
is
to see him good is really thank you it's
really good for us for the
for me and especially to see
to see you good
your and your person is is the best
thing in thank you very much brother
thank you i truly appreciate that
he said the first sentence that he found
you know when you lost at boston douglas
in japan
you saw
[Music]
even though you may not be mexican mike
you're mexican to the mexican people
you can choose it oh
that's cool man well guys thank you for
the show and any other last questions
man this was fun man to get a chance to
talk to you know two two living legends
should be um
he's a cool kid and i never had a chance
to sit down and have a conversation
really good guy thank you mike yeah mike
you guys have a lot of similarities mike
getting a chance to hear his philosophy
in life in years
it's awesome life is what you make it
whatever you think you are a smoker a
great guy that's who you are you're
right muchachos guys thank you so much
for uh you know for joining us you did a
great job though thank you mike thank
you man you better tell uncle rob man
but i appreciate it he did a great job
now to me it's an honor mike to be able
to uh you know
practice english
foreign i'm gonna
learn more english
this is cool
spanish is cool too don't forget that
i know some people they come here and
forget all they don't talk spanish no
more no no no yeah spanish as always i
always
always remember where you're from
yeah
that's all you got thank you thank you
very much
this is hot boxing with mike tyson and i
am your co-host triple c henry cejudo
and i'm mike tyson we're out
[Music]
mike tyson raves in full bloom have
captured the art of fighting the
hollywood reporter says it's mallet
meets corceso
full bloom
available now on amazon prime video
you